le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social le conseil
départemental aux côtés des réunionnais
véritables ambassadeurs de la
citoyenneté
les jeunes conseillers départementaux
ont un certain investissement au sein de
notre institution
ils sont tous motivés impliqués et
représente l'avenir créer un espace de
dialogue améliorer l'image des jeunes en
montrant leur capacité à prendre des
décisions sont les rôles de cette
population de jeunes réunionnais qui
échange avec les élus quelle mission et
que font exactement les conseillers
départementaux jeunes on en parle tout
de suite dans lien social tous les
collèges de la réunion participe au
conseil départemental
c'est l'opportunité pour les jeunes
conseillers départementaux issus des
classes de 4e et de 3e de s'investir au
sein du conseil départemental ainsi de
participer à la construction de la
société de demain
chaque année scolaire de nouveaux jeunes
sont élus qui porteront la réalisation
de projets faisant appel à leur
dynamisme et leur créativité et qui leur
permettront d'affiner leur regard sur
notre société
le bilan et le passage de relais entre
anciens et nouveaux élus montrent bien
l'application à faire connaître les
mécanismes de la démocratie et la
gestion locale la présidente sortante
eve marolles a très bien représentée et
a défendu ses projets avec volonté et
conviction
ma motivation de mon année en tant que
présidente du conseil départemental des
jeunes
ça a été surtout de m'impliquer dans ce
rôle que je ne connaissais pas avant et
de découvrir un peu la politique et la
citoyenneté
j'ai pu partager des tas de choses avec
avec ces jeunes justement et j'ai eu
envie voilà que la jeunesse réunionnaise
s'implique dans la société réunionnaise
justement pensez pas un loisir de plus
c'est vraiment un rôle très important à
prendre puisque on parle de la jeunesse
réunionnaise et c'est pas quelque chose
à prendre à la légère on a eu des
projets très importants qu'on a menées
toute l'année tels que le
cyberharcèlement qu'on a énormément où
on a énormément travaillé dessus j'ai pu
faire d'eux des rencontres incroyables
que je pensais pas du tout j'ai
rencontré des femmes et des hommes
politiques
j'ai pu vraiment m'impliquer dans la vie
citoyenne et c'est pas forcément facile
j'ai aussi et surtout travailler avec
des jeunes de toute l'île c'est c'est
vraiment une expérience inoubliable
puisque c'est une chose qu'on vit une
fois dans sa vie est forcément c'est une
sacrée expérience
c'est une véritable école de la
démocratie de la citoyenneté
c'est une instance qui a été créée en
1989 et qui concerne les collégiens de
4e et de 3e pour une mandature de deux
ans donc cette instance a été mise en
place pour à permettre à ces collégiens
de pouvoir s'exprimer en public de
participer à la vie de la cité de leur
collège
et puis de pouvoir s'exprimer de donner
des idées sur leurs thématiques sur sur
des conduites de projets a à faire
pendant leur mandature
il faut savoir que le conseil
départemental regroupe quand même tous
les collèges du département à savoir
deux élèves par collège en 4e et en 3e
ils ont un mandat de deux ans et au bout
de ce mandat donc ils peuvent travailler
sur des thématiques qui leur tiennent à
coeur
on constate avec joie quand même que le
les jeunes il s'implique puisque il ya
quand même 15 candidats qui se
positionne pour prendre le prendre le
poste de helmand et lors de cette
réunion préparatoire donc on peut voir
que ces jeunes sont déterminés sont
motivés et ils ont envie de s'investir
dans cette instance
la première assemblée plénière elle
devra se dérouler le 13 novembre
donc là il ya eu la réunion préparatoire
où j'ai réuni tous les candidats à la
présidence pour leur expliquer leur
responsabilité et leur investissement en
sortant de cette réunion préparatoire
ils sont quand même plus confiant et je
dois dire que ça il ya des personnes qui
sortent du lot et on voit à peu près qui
pourrait qui pourrait gagner la
présidence à la suite de cette nouvelle
élection du 13 novembre dernier au
palais de la source c'est jade tongs it
qui devient présidente du conseil
départemental des jeunes pour 2015 2016
pour preuve d'amour entre nous pour vous
en prendre vraiment à le rejoindre de me
prévenir que les gagnants qui ont voté
aux confiance en moi et qu'ils ont cru
en mes preuves et qu'il espère du corps
à terme j'ai décidé de me présenter au
président du conseil départemental des
jeunes pour être le porte parole de la
chambre criminelle et parce que le
projet car ce projet que je pense en
toute modestie est il adapté à la
tendance ministre les quatre sessions
creusé dans mon programme sont déjà une
rencontre interculturelle pour apprendre
la connaître à mieux connaître les
différentes cultures de notre île
car pour moi la laïcité et la tolérance
sont deux points très importants
deuxièmement il ya l'installation de
poubelles de tri dans tous les collèges
de ville sans lui tendu contre on ne
savait pas vraiment trier ne connaissait
pas les conséquences une clé
troisièmement de la prévention contrats
liés au diester les infections
sexuellement transmissibles
car il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
encore infectés et quatrièmement
l'anniversaire des délais des classes en
1945 a été créé la fonction de chef de
classe et j'aimerais que l'on célèbre ça
en organisant une grande formation
d'années de vie croît et je vais tout
faire trop s'impliquer dans la vie de la
collectivité quoi de plus noble pour nos
jeunes réunionnais leur donner la parole
écoutez leurs projets les développer et
avoir leur vision de demain
une année riche se prépare pour nos
jeunes soyons confiants pour la relève
et souhaitons leur bon courage le
conseil départemental de la réunion vous
a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais